what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and today we
have some really really cool venom 2 let
there be carnage news but also some news
about venom 3. it's looking like venom 2
let there be carnage is actually on the
path to be a very successful film
despite the release date being delayed
for 3 weeks but if you think about it it
being delayed is actually kind of a good
sign that means they really want people
to see this movie that means they
believe in the movie they actually do
think it's going to be pretty good and
they just want as many people as they
can to see it and tom hardy himself as
i'll talk about in today's video is very
pleased with venom 2 and is already
planning venom 3 and he wants spider-man
to be in the film tom holland spider-man
specifically and today i'll go over
everything that tom hardy specifically
has said about venom three and if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest venom spider-man
and marvel news so tom hardy has already
begun to work on venom 3. venom 2 has
obviously been done for some time now
and it's ready to be released in
theaters and according to tom hardy what
he said in an interview with esquire
magazine it's actually pretty dang good
and he's pretty pleased with it he also
revealed that he wrote a fair amount of
the story in fact in venom let there be
carnage he is even going to get story by
credits alongside screenwriter kelly
marcel so he was very very involved with
this story and it looks like he wants to
be even more involved with venom three
in the interview he said i'm thinking
about the third movie as well because i
think you need to write that at the same
time a third won't be green lit until
the second is successful but the studio
was really really pleased with number
two so first thing to acknowledge here
venom 2 let there be carnage obviously
isn't going to suck if tom hardy himself
is so satisfied with it that he wants to
write a third movie and the studio is
really really pleased with it it clearly
isn't a disaster it's actually going to
be probably pretty good and based off of
the teaser that we saw and the trailer
that we saw it does look pretty good i
think carnage himself looks very very
good i don't think he's toned down at
all i think it's serious but provides
also a lot of comedy and i think that
tom hardy and woody harrelson are going
to do great together on screen and tom
hardy definitely said more that we'll
get into but my takeaway from this is
that venom 2 is going to be good and
they're going to do a third venom film
but then of course esquire magazine had
to ask about the possibilities of tom
holland spider-man showing up in the
third venom film and based off of what
tom hardy said that's actually what he's
going for here's what tom hardy had to
say i would be remiss if i wasn't trying
to steer any kind of connectivity i
wouldn't be doing the job if i wasn't
awake and open to any opportunity or
eventuality or be excited by that
obviously that's a large canyon to leap
to be bridged by one person alone and it
would take a much higher level of
diplomacy and intelligence sitting down
and talking to take on an arena such as
that should both sides be willing and it
be beneficial to both sides i don't see
why it couldn't be i hope and strongly
with both hands push eagerly towards
that potential and would do anything to
make that happen within what's right in
business but it would be foolish not to
head towards olympic games if you were
running a hundred meters so yeah i want
to play on that field so i think that's
pretty much as straightforward that tom
hardy can get he says that he is eagerly
pushing with both hands towards the
direction of spider-man and venom coming
face to face in venom three he refers to
that crossover as the olympic games and
he would be foolish not to go for it
these are his own words he even says
that he would do anything to make it
happen so as far as what is on tom
hardy's mind in terms of venom 3 well
spider-man is on his mind specifically
tom holland spider-man tom hardy wants
spider-man and venom 3 and he says he's
going to do anything that he can to make
that happen this makes me wonder if
carnage is going to die at the end of
venom 2. obviously venom 3 has not been
written yet but it sure would be really
really cool if we had a spider-man and
venom versus carnage moment and i guess
i should say that we technically don't
know that tom holland isn't going to be
in venom 2 but for right now since we've
had no type of confirmation for that at
all i'm not going to count on that do i
hope yes but i actually really don't
think he's going to be in the film but
hopefully venom 3 goes the way tom hardy
wants it to go because if it does then
we will finally have a spider-man vs
venom film and it probably is going to
be pretty dang epic so good news for
venom fans and good news for spidey fans
it looks like venom 2 is actually going
to be pretty dang good which i expected
and the hopes and most importantly the
potential and actuality that spider-man
could end up in venom 3 is very very
real and strong tom hardy is going to do
everything and anything that he can like
he said to make it happen and i think
the studios could probably agree that it
would be a pretty beneficial move to
have a spider-man and venom film so
hopefully they agree and tom hardy makes
it happen but be sure to let me know
your thoughts on this in the comments
down below would you like to see a venom
versus spidey movie i don't know why i'm
asking i'm sure everybody would love
that so instead just let me know what
you would want from it don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
venom or spidey news for live updates
you can always follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof